finalmente
Qué papel ha tenido la situación
económica en estas elecciones
a la luz de la
pandemia se endeudó más empezaron los
turcos a ver que la lida turca valía
menos es decir empezaban a comprar menos
y también tuvo ahí un rol que ver la
cuestión de las vacunas después de que
concluye y que se empieza a difuminar la
pandemia a la luz de la guerra en
Ucrania Turquía se vio muy afectado por
la proveeduría del trigo a toda su
población entonces aquí es donde vemos a
Turquía que empieza a vivir un tsunami
económico por las consecuencias
económicas de la guerra a nivel global y
entonces los turcos empiezan a palpar
que no solamente las cosas cuestan más
caras sino y o bien que pueden comprar
ahora menos sino que más su salario no
alcanza que hay una gran corrupción al
interior del país de acuerdo a
transparencia internacional Turquía se
encuentra por encima
de los 100 de las cien posiciones como
los países más corruptos esto no había
cobrado factura Rosa Pero en qué momento
en Turquía en el sismo de seis de
febrero la corrupción se desborda sale
como si fuera vapor de una olla Exprés
cuando quede en evidencia y se desnuda
que los edificios habían sido Eh Pues
otorgados por adjudicación directa por
el amigo porque erdogan tiene una red de
empresarios que lo apoyan Pero porque
tienen negocios con familiares de la
familia de erdogan Entonces cuando
empezamos a entender esta madeja y a
desmenuzarla pues vemos que claro que la
corrupción ha llegado a consumir el
altísimo costo de más de cincuenta y
cinco mil vidas de turcos que cobró este
sismo y entonces vemos las estadísticas
de febrero la la tasa de aprobación de
erdogan empezó a bajar mucho Rosa y
entonces él ya sabía que tenía que
calentar los motores de marketing
político de estas elecciones de hoy y
vemos como su nivel de aprobación
comenzó a subir al a a al límite que
esta semana él dio la instrucción que a
una gran cantidad de funcionarios
públicos les aumentaran el sueldo esto
es finalmente comprar votos y y esto
este hartazgo económico es lo que
propició que la oposición se forretera y
que hoy la alianza nacional que agrupa
seis partidos políticos sea la apuesta
de los turcos que ya no quieren más de
dos décadas a él en el poder pero
tampoco debemos de olvidar que también
gemal es la apuesta de occidente para
poder planear un poco más hacia Europa y
distanciar al gobierno Turco de lo que
es con Vladimir